شكرا لك
[موسيقى]
أوليمبياد ريو ،
إنه لأمر رائع أن يكون لدينا
العرض الأول في الشرق الأوسط في مهرجان القاهرة
السينمائي الدولي لسبب شخصي بالنسبة
لي لأنني نصف مصري وترعرعت
في القاهرة لذلك شعرت أنني عائد إلى
المنزل مع  الفيلم وأيضًا كان
أول جمهور عربي يشاهد الفيلم
وكان مثيرًا جدًا بالنسبة لي لأنني
أعتقد أن الجمهور العربي
سيفهم الفيلم أكثر من معظم السنوات الماضية
وسارة مارديني الأشوريات ، فتيات عربيات حديثات السن
لذا أعتقد أنه سيكون هناك  كن
تفاهمًا
واتصالًا أعمق معهم
، أشعر بطريقة أن القصة
اختارتني أو اتصل بي عنوان العمل ، وكان
لديهم سيناريو كتبه جاك ثورن
وأخبروني أنه كان يتعلق فقط بـ
يسرا مارديني ، لذلك عندما قرأته ،
اكتشفت سارة في النص لم أكن
أعرف أنها موجودة لأنني سمعت عن
يسرا في الأخبار عندما كانت في
أولمبياد ريو لكنني لم أكن أعرف أن
هناك أختًا ثانية ولم أكن أعرف
أنها كانت  بطل فقط
تمامًا مثل يسرا ، لذلك وجدت أنها كانت
ملهمة للغاية أن هذه كانت قصة
أخوات عن بطلتين ، ويمكنني
حقًا أن أتواصل معهما بوصفهما
امرأة عربية ليبرالية شابة حديثة ، وعلى الرغم
من وجود فارق في السن وترعرعت
في القاهرة ، فقد ذكروني بذلك.  نسخة صغيرة
من
نفسي ، ذكّروني بنسخة صغيرة من
نفسي ، لذا فإن هذا الارتباط
وحقيقة أنني أستطيع الارتباط بهم جعلني أرغب
في القيام بالفيلم
الذي أعتقده كبشر بالطريقة التي
تمر بها في أصعب الأوقات أو بالتأكيد
أنا  مررت بأوقات عصيبة في حياتي
مع الفكاهة والضحك ورأيت
ذلك بسرعة كبيرة عندما التقيت بيستيرا
وسارة أنت تعلم أن الطريقة التي تعاملوا
بها مع المشقة كانت بالضحك مع
بعضهم البعض وهذا ما ساعدهم
على تجاوز الأمر وأعتقد أنه  هذا
رد فعل بشري على المأساة والتعامل
مع الألم ، إنه مرتبط للغاية
وأردت حقًا أن يظهر الفيلم هذه الأم ،
لذلك كان من المتعمد أن
يكون لديك هذا الارتفاع بالإضافة إلى أن التصوير
كان عملاً حقيقيًا.  اختبار الآس الذي كنا
نصوره أثناء الطمع ، لذا فقد تم تصوير جميع الأقنعة في
بلد القائمة الحمراء ، وقد تم تصوير معظم الفيلم
في تركيا أيضًا ، وقد صورنا أيضًا في
ألمانيا والمملكة المتحدة وبلجيكا ، لكن كانت تركيا
بشكل أساسي ولأن الفيلم هو فيلم طريق
أنت  فقط في مكان ما مرة واحدة وبعد
ذلك عليك المضي قدمًا ولدينا
أطفال حيوانات تسقي كل الأشياء
التي يقول الناس إنها لا تفعلها كمخرج
لأنها معقدة لدينا في
هذا الفيلم
ولكنها واحدة من أكثر الأجزاء صعوبة
كنا نصور المعبر وذهبنا إلى
ساحل بحر إيجه حيث سافرت يسرى
وسارة بالفعل ، وعندما
كنا هناك
رأينا قوارب خفر السواحل تطارد
الزوارق وقمنا بتصويرها في نفس
المكان حيث كان هذا يحدث بالفعل
لذلك وضعنا زورقًا في الماء
ووضعنا 25 ممثلاً على القارب
وخرجنا إلى البحر وكنت في زورق آخر
بالكاميرا
وكنا مرتبطين بالزورق البطل وأحيانًا لا نعلقه ونتحرك
حوله ببحرية
الفريق أيضًا ، لكننا كنا حقًا تحت رحمة الأمواج ، كان لدينا يومين لتصوير هذا التسلسل وعندما ترى الممثلين يتقيأون ، كانوا يتقيئون حقًا لأنهم أصيبوا بدوار البحر بسرعة كبيرة بالطريقة التي يتحرك بها القارب في الماء هكذا عندما إنه مزدحم ، كان الفيلم تعليميًا بالنسبة لي بالطبع كان لديّ أفكاري وأفكاري حول هذا الموضوع ، لكنني أعتقد أنه كان يلتقي بالعديد من اللاجئين أثناء صنع الفيلم وأيضًا اختيارهم في الفيلم حيث يعمل اللاجئون على فيلم ما وراء الكواليس لقد أحضرت لي للتو كيف يمكن أن يكون هذا نحن لا يمكن لأحد أن يتخيل جائحة عالمي وأن العالم بأسره يتوقف ولكن مع تغير المناخ والأشياء التي تحدث على المستوى العالمي في العالم ، فأنت تدرك الآن أن هناك الكثير من الأسباب وراء نزوح الناس ليس فقط الحرب أو السياسة ، فأنت تعلم أن عدم المساواة في عالمنا والفقر كما تعلم هو أحد الأسباب ولكن أيضًا تغير المناخ أعتقد أننا سنشهد المزيد من نزوح الناس أم ر  إنه شيء لا يمثل قصة إخبارية
ولا يتم نقله إلى
منطقة واحدة من العالم ، فهناك لاجئون
عبر التاريخ انتقلوا إلى
جميع أنحاء العالم ونحن جميعًا جزء من
هذه القصة ، فقد تكون أنت أو أنا
غدًا هذه هي الحقيقة
[موسيقى  ]